[Music]
hello and welcome to this video
yeah I'm very excited to now present to
you my latest product on chasuble and
it's called fight one e-form like
Khurana it was announced that you go on
my channel that this is in the works and
now it is completed ready and you can
buy it on chasuble calm so what is it
all about it's a full black repertoire
and we became a look at the chapters now
it's a full black repertoire to fight
1.e4 based on the double King pawn to e4
e5 and it covers everything that might
happen that means we will have the first
chapter for example here on all the the
gambit variations that can happen the
King's gambit yeah we can have a look at
some Kings gambit craziness right here
when I click them so we have some
weapons against all the gambits we have
lines against early deviations like the
vienna game the bishops opening all
those lines that can be played on with
two we also of course have to feature
something against 293 and that will be
the petrov
it's called fight before like karana
karana has really made a formidable
weapon out of the petrov we will cover
the petrov proper everything that might
happen 3d for 9065 the modern main line
with 593 so everything in the petrov is
covered but also if wide declines
basically the petrov and he can do so by
going 393 we will get the four knights
opening so it also has that included the
four knights
spanish the phone add scotch all those
lines that you would even be yeah very
happy to get some coverage of if you
don't play the patch
and don't tend to do that however I
think the matter of coverage is
excellent and really happy with the
lines many lines are extremely exciting
and very very tactical so it's really a
an interesting way to fight with black
what I definitely need to show to you if
you are new to chasuble is how this
actually works because it's not a
classic let's say a book or anything
it's rather what it is called like the
move trainer it really helps you to
learn the lines move by mouth so how
does that work let's say I go into a
chapter and I want to learn a certain
line I could select the line from a list
of lines but I can also say okay show me
something that I have not yet learned
and that would be I mean I learned one
or two lines before I started the video
so I'm going here and it now will show
me what you do in this particular
position so I'm clicking next and says
ok you move take only four well ok and
there's a text that you can read - yeah
better understand what this move should
be played yeah and then I basically have
to place them on the board and now ok I
have to go back ok so let's do that so I
can't learn move by move basically the
opening it always has the information
why a certain move should be played and
what the ideas are behind the moves the
great thing is that the software
recognizes the spots where you make
mistakes and those will be presented to
you again and again so all those holes
that you might have in repertoire will
be patched automatically this is the
great thing about such a sophisticated
software so if we go back down and check
out the video again I actually made a
Mis click there so how does the video
yeah combined with the Move trainer this
is great
now if you are in the video yeah like
here I have a screenshot in the middle
of a video I'm jumping to a different
spot I am somewhere in the repertoire I
can filter
based on the video position so if I'm in
the video and I want to learn more about
this particular line that is shown in
the video I can click on filter and it
will filter out all the lines so I can
get more information there on the text
on the text base if I want like I see
that the video picture and listen to the
explanation then I think I need to
really reread that so
you just jump into this part you can
read the text and then you can work from
there like copy the position twin to put
it into analysis engine things like that
you can all do that also in the video
page there's another feature that it's
excellent when you are actually in a
certain line and you have the opposite
idea like okay let's say here I want to
watch the video on that particular
position so you can jump to the video
position and then you can watch me
explain the ideas behind that line so
that it works in two ways I think it's
an excellent way to learn openings I
always use my own opening products that
say to repeat my own openings I prepare
with the Move trainer to record the
videos and it works excellently well so
this is a product that has the the basic
move trainer function with all the texts
and the ability to have this spaced
repetition for the moves and it has the
videos and I need to tell you how it is
actually priced if we go to the starting
page again I have a better overview
there so we have the basic move trainer
variation since all that moves all the
variations all the text this is 674
variations give or take one or two I
might find one I need to add all you
need so 670 roughly variations and it
has more than 50,000 words which is huge
it's really it's a huge chunk of text
and explain
you also get included with the basic
version close to four hours of video the
first chapter with all the gambits will
be included plus a preview of all the
other chapters of like roughly ten
minutes so I have a good impression how
the other videos look like and this is
priced at $30 29:20 $29.99 now I always
have issues with those numbers in
English so let me run up 30 and 30
dollars but we will have a sale for I
think it is 10 days and at that time it
would only be priced at 50% of that so
it will be 14.99 $15 basically which is
real steel if you ask me then you have
the option to get the full videos which
means it is not going to be the close to
four hours but in addition of 14 hours
roughly of videos so we would have
almost like two hour of video per
chapter and you can also get that of
course and buy the video add-on which is
at normal times non-sale time priced at
102 39.99 dollars 140 dollars and this
is reduced more than 50% even during the
sale - its 60 4.99
$65 so if you purchase the whole thing
during sale it's below 80 US dollars
yeah I think it's it's really it's great
value and all those and the videos
really make it a terrific product and
pretty much it's very much appreciated
if you get the full package because that
really makes the whole product yeah
worth producing with that effort that I
put into so I hope you liked the preview
and that you're interested in the
product I think it's it's a great way to
build an opening repertoire based on the
double King pawn with black um based on
kiwanis choices yeah I've really really
tried to model it after what come on a
place in most cases it works very well
in some
the lines are obscure and not played on
the world-class level in this case I
have selected good lines I think that
are interesting and exciting to play
against those rarer continuation so I
think it's a it's a great way to expand
and improve your opening repertoire make
sure to check it out on chasuble comm
thanks for watching
[Music]